[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 60,18
bienvenue dans cette édition
tout de suite les titres de ce lundi 26
mars est la visite du ministre de
l'éducation nationale à montigny le
bretonneux jean michel blanquer air
s'est rendu au lycée emilie de breteuil
un déplacement orientée vers les
sciences dans un établissement qui
propose justement des formations en ce
sens reportage comme à chaque fin de
mois le dossier de la rédaction cette
semaine nous vous proposons une série de
reportages sur les métiers de la
gendarmerie des yvelines nous suivrons
dans ce journal est la cellule
d'identification criminelle qui
recherchent l'adn et les empreintes
digitales lors des enquêtes
et puis d'anciennes gloires du psg
réunis par le brésilien raï pour la
bonne cause le 15e trophée gol de letra
se tenait samedi au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines un match
servant à récolter des fonds en faveur
des enfants des favelas ce brésil
football également avec nos invités ils
représentent les clubs de plaisir
maurepas et guyancourt trois équipes
engagées le week-end prochain et dans
les demi finales de la coupe des
yvelines
on en parle dans un instant on parlera
aussi dans ce journal de l'europe avec
regin a le coin secrétaire général et de
la maison de l'europe des yvelines elle
accueillait sur le territoire une
rencontre transnationales on vous en dit
plus dans un instant je vous disais dans
les titres vendredi après midi le lycée
emilie de breteuil en continu le
bretonneux a reçu la visite du ministre
de l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanchard était accompagné du député de
l'essonne cédric villani il est l'auteur
d'un rapport sur l'enseignement des
mathématiques
au programme du déplacement séquences
pédagogiques et tables rondes avec la
communauté éducative les précisions avec
ce sujet doré lire 11 et patrick jacques
de dixmude un cours de chimie un peu
particulier dans cette classe du lycée
emilie de breteuil de montigny le
bretonneux les élèves extrait de l'huile
essentielle d'un clou de girofle sous
les yeux du ministre de l'éducation
nationale
jean michel blanquer a tenu à visiter
cet établissement qui mène de nombreux
projets scientifiques
s'il ya tout un travail assez avant
garde
qui préfigure un peu ce que nous
souhaitons au travers de la réforme du
baccalauréat et au travers de la réforme
des différentes filières qui est de
réussir à donner des parcours
scientifique variées aux élèves sciences
de l'ingénieur ou encore systèmes
d'information et numérique
le lycée emilie de breteuil propose
plusieurs spécialités et formations liés
aux sciences encourager les carrières
scientifiques c'est notamment ce que
souhaite le gouvernement
sur ce thème le député de l'essonne
cédric villani a d'ailleurs rendu en
février dernier un rapport sur
l'enseignement des mathématiques dans
les témoignages qu'on a vu aujourd'hui
celui de 7h enseignante qui disaient
certains élèves qui se pensent move et
en mathématiques sont quand même de bons
programmes heures alors que ce que
demande la programmation c'est de la
rigueur de la logique de la
compréhension exactement ce qui est à la
base de l'enseignement mathématiques
lors de cette visite le ministre de
l'éducation nationale s'est également
entretenu avec la communauté éducative
sur la réforme du baccalauréat dès la
rentrée 2010 8 les élèves qui entreront
en seconde ne devront plus opter pour
une série mais pour des disciplines de
spécialités les rythmes scolaires en
débat à la verrière samedi une
quarantaine de personnes a assisté à la
concertation publique organisée par la
ville une réunion pour discuter prendre
une décision sur la durée de la pause
méridienne en école primaire
problématique y donner suffisamment de
temps
le midi à l'enfant pour manger souffler
et revenir dans les meilleures
conditions aux classes l'après midi
finalement une coupure d'une heure 45
entre 11h30 et 13h 15 a été votée la
verrière qui associe régulièrement ses
habitants au choix de la commune comme
le précise le maire au micro de nicolas
landry à chaque fois qu'on a une
décision à prendre sur cette ville on
essaye au maximum d'en discuter avec les
habitants de
de voir ce qu'ils en pensent et
d'essayer de trouver un consensus
donc là il va y avait des représentants
de l'éducation nationale des animateurs
du périscolaire et des parents tout le
monde à vous avez vu tout le monde a
bien discuté
bon les les avis étaient partagés
fallait prendre une décision finale mais
au moins on discute politique la
république en marche en route vers les
élections européennes de 2019 le parti
présidentiel met en place sa grande
marche pour le scrutin le lancement
officiel de la campagne prévue ce
week-end a été finalement reportée en
raison des attentats de trèbes et
carcassonne
une réunion de préparation s'est tenue
tout de même jeudi dernier à saint
germain en laye reportage de nicolas
landry et mickaël medoro c'est la
version européenne de la grande marche
de la présidentielle de 2016 le parti
des manuels macron se lance dans les
élections européennes de 2019
en partant à la rencontre des français
on a besoin d'aller à la rencontre des
français comme on l'avait fait en 2016
est là pour parler de l'europe savoir ce
qu'ils en attente qui marche qui marche
pas ce qui va nous permettra de
construire ce projet européen qui ne
servira de base pour les élections
européennes de 2010 moi je pense qu'il
faut donner au citoyen le goût de
l'europe parce que on voit bien que
depuis des années les participations aux
élections européennes par exemple elles
baissent de plus en plus parce que les
gens ne vois pas où est l'utilité de
l'europe il faut leur montrer en fait à
quel point l'europe est utile dans leur
vie se porte à porte voulu par la
république en marche se veut pédagogique
autour des enjeux de l'union européenne
notamment après les 57 % d'abstention
lors des élections européennes de 2014
en france un taux de près de 54% dans
les yvelines
le département des yvelines travaille
d'ailleurs avec un fonds social pour
l'europe
on a aujourd'hui
millions d'euros avec lequel donc des
fonds européens qui permettent aux
départements de travailler pour faire en
sorte qu'il y ait moins de pauvreté au
niveau du département donc l'europe est
présente au quotidien dans les yvelines
l'europe concerne les gens de plusieurs
manières les financements la protection
des consommateurs la protection de la
santé la protection des libertés à peu
près 40% des lois auxquelles vous
obéissez nous obéissons elles sont
écrites voté à bruxelles et seulement
transposé dans le droit français
la campagne du parti présidentiel ne
fait que commencer les élections
européennes se tiendront fin mai 2019
pour élire 74 eurodéputés français on
continue de parler de l'europe avec ce
projet pour redynamiser les zones
rurales riz dit c'est un projet erasmus
plus financé par l'union européenne et
dans le cadre de cette opération des
associations de six pays dont la france
ont visité les yvelines pendant trois
jours en fin de semaine dernière une
première rencontre transnationales sur
laquelle revient à camille lambert
c'est ici au lycée agricole et horticole
de saint germain en laye que sont formés
les futurs paysagistes fleuriste ou
scientifique bio écologiques
aujourd'hui il ouvre ses portes à des
représentants de six pays différents
dans le cadre d'un projet erasmus
accueillis par la maison de l'europe des
yvelines
by beating aucun échange un peu ce que
font les uns et les autres dans leurs
pays respectifs
parce qu'on sait très bien le problème
partout en europe si la désertification
du milieu rural qu'elle est
les jeunes partent
et qu'y voir aller dans les villes et
veulent plus être agriculteur plus
s'installer
c'était de pouvoir les orienter par
rapport à nos problématiques qu'on peut
avoir nous sur sur l'île de france et
peut-être façon plus globale en france
sur le circuit court
comment interagir avec notre nos
consommateurs délégation allemande grec
polonaises et suédoises ont participé à
cette première rencontre transnationales
le projet riz dit souhaite promouvoir la
citoyenneté active dans les zones
rurales
une série de visites étaient prévues
dans les yvelines pendant plusieurs
jours c'était vraiment intéressant qu'à
saint germain et cette région de
versailles sont à côté de paris a donc
c'est plus comme une banlieue mais qui
reste très rural quand on compare à la
pologne
c'est vraiment très différent les
distances entre chaque village ou
grandes villes sont bien plus grandes
match à 24 participants peut découvrir
le territoire et échanger pour savoir
comment redynamiser les zones rurales
européenne la prochaine rencontre
transnationales aura lieu en suède en
septembre 2018 et pour parler de ce
projet une invitée m'a rejoint un
plateau vous l'avez vu dans ce reportage
reguena lecointe ce bon score aux femmes
d'être la secrétaire général de la
maison de l'europe décisive une située à
saint germain en laye alors la maison de
l'europe des yvelines qui fait partie de
ce projet est financé par le programme
erasmus plus vous avez accueilli donc
cette première rencontre transnationales
quel bilan vous vous tirez de ces
échanges ses premiers échanges
guy côté malgré la grève et tous les
petits soucis qu'on avait autour de cela
c'était vraiment un très grand succès
que ce soit pour nos partenaires locaux
que pour les
nos européens qui ont découvert une un
département surprenant pour eux parce
que il arrivé à saint germain il voit
une au château il était à versailles
voyant château est une ville dit mais où
est la ruralité et quand on est sorti
déjà pour les lycées agricoles
ils ont vu qu'il y avait déjà des champs
et après affaires mesure on est allé
plus loin et on a terminé dans une vraie
ferme
db oui quel a été le programme on a vu
dans ce reportage l'étranger au lycée
agricole et horticole de saint germain
en laye qu'est-ce qu'elle a été la suite
de la visite qu est ce qu il fallait
montrer sur ces trois jours de visite
sur les haies mais il fallait surtout
voir comment fonctionne le département
des yvelines
pourquoi la ruralité on n'y pense pas
tout de suite compte en moi comme je
disais versailles et saint germain et on
a fait ça progressivement n'a commencé
donc avec le conseil départemental
parce que c'est le conseil départemental
avait lancé les assises de la ruralité
d'accord donc madame unis courent
lefebvre nous a très gentiment à cris et
a expliqué pourquoi sir
ces assises quel était leur but était
invité une amère date qui vraiment une
en village de 400 bas
habitant la crise le maire de
rambouillet qui rambouillet qui devenue
la capitale de la ruralité ont pour voir
déjà les différences et décliné ont
commencé à comment sont tout en haut
pour aller pour terminer à la ferme
vraiment à voir comment ça se déclinent
chez nous est d'avoir la preuve notre
propre problématique parce qu'on est
quand même périurbain et à l'ombre de
paris et la problématique c'est aussi le
les origines de ce projet j'ai dit c'est
que les zones rurales sont des clans ça
c'est un constat qu'ont effectué les
années 60 non on avait fait ça c'est ce
constat avec nos pays partenaires
on avait tous les mêmes problèmes en
disant il n'y a pas que nous et aussi
d'autres pays européens qui a le même
problème et on a dit il faut faire
quelque chose du coup les objectifs de
ce projet c'est de l'échangé bonnes
pratiques de voir comment
les uns et les autres gèrent cette
problématique où les solutions qu'ils
ont parce qu'il craint pas que du
négatif et surtout aussi des belles
traditions que les gens ont et donc la
finalité aussi de décrire en manuel des
bonnes pratiques produire voilà un
prostate est le problème on a telle et
telle solution est de dire ben oui tiens
ça c'est adapte à prononcer le nom ça ça
va pas pour notre région
mais comme puisque c'est un petit peu
dedans en disant oui
finalement c'est une bonne idée ce
qu'ils ont un peu peut-être adapter sa
ici et ça va durer deux ans et ça ça va
durer deux ans parce que entre chaque
rencontre on travaille sur la prochaine
thématique d'accord ou cas là ça va être
un as fed
donc on à septembre au genre en
septembre ça va être en suède et là ça
va être entre la nature et la délégation
suédoise nous apprend à présenter des
projets vraiment très intéressant et
pourquoi est il important pour la maison
de l'europe des vignes de faire partie
de ce projet finalement pourquoi c'est
important qu'ils touchent aux
européennes dans le développement des
yvelines rurales selon disons que moi je
suis très attaché à la ruralité c'est
pas pour nous trop l'europe c'est très
important
lesca remparts toujours de la défense
européenne mais si on n'a pas si on
n'est pas indépendant au niveau agricole
comment voulez vous
agir n'importe quel général à vous dire
si j'ai pas le ravitaillement parce que
le blé ça vient du brésil a bien ça
vient de l'argentine et on est en
bisbille avec eux on fait quoi
donc il faut qu'on soit assis mais voilà
absolument indépendant et on l'a dit
prochaines rencontres en national ça
sera en suède en septembre prochain il
nous reste un peu moins d'une minute
peut-être un mot sur la maison de
l'europe pour finir la maison l'europe
des yvelines qui avait quelles sont ses
missions ses missions sont surtout
l'information la formation sur les
institutions européennes sur tout ce que
l'europe fait elle a fait en partie avec
lors de notre visite
en parlant des programmes est leader qui
est un programme européen preneur pour
allaiter justement et
donc pour expliquer aux jeunes aux
jeunes on parle de la mobilité en europe
parce que pour réussir d'entendre bouger
de connaître les voisins pour avoir la
conscience de la citoyenneté européenne
parce que si vous n'avez pas ça ça se
fait pas d'accord il faut se sentira pas
trop appartenir à l'union pour vraiment
pensé et pas avoir vu connaître ces
jeunes donc précise qu'elle est à saint
germain en laye vous pouvez retrouver
toutes les informations sur le site
internet de la maison de l'europe des
yvelines qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci reguena lecointe d'avoir est avec
nous secrétaire général de la maison de
l'europe des yvelines à notre dossier de
la rédaction est consacré cette semaine
à la gendarmerie nationale des yvelines
plusieurs activités et plusieurs
services ce soir découverte de la
cellule d'information criminelle est des
gendarmes en blouse blanche équipée
d'outils pourrait chercher est l'adn ou
des empreintes digitales sur les scènes
de crime un reportage de nicolas landry
accidentelle ou criminelle c'est la
question pour ces deux techniciens
d'identification criminelle de la
gendarmerie nationale des yvelines
accompagné par un pompier spécialistes
ils recherchent des indices dans cette
maison 24 heures après l incendie
objectif découvrir la cause du sinistre
prononcez pas laisser passer pro
criminelle
on a respecté les gravats quand je vous
disais tout à l'heure il n'y a pas
d'odeur d'accélérant de carburant ou de
matières suspect après un premier bilan
avec le pompier cette intervention est
terminée pour les techniciens
d'identification criminelle
les plus connus sont de miami ou de
manhattan mais les experts sont aussi
dans les yvelines
cinq techniciens au sein de la cellule
d'identification criminelle de
versailles la majorité de leurs
activités trouver des indices à travers
des méthodes scientifiques pour aider
les enquêteurs notamment sur des
homicides
donc là on a fait une représentation
d'une scène une découverte de cadavres
donc les premiers arrivés souvent sont
les voisins qui sont en galère que les
services de gendarmerie ou les services
de secours
une fois que l'on intervient la première
chose que l'on va faire c'est figé la
scène à l'aide d'un appareil photo
numérique
on va faire ce qu'on appelle une
triangulation prendre sous différents
angles la pièce et ce qui s'y passe
histoire de la figer dans un deuxième
temps on va faire un ratissage de cette
zone de la pièce entre autres pour
pouvoir marquer à l'aide de numérotation
les traces et indices qui nous
paraissent pertinentes et qui ne
pourront permettre de résoudre
éventuellement l'enquète ou en tout cas
nous permettre de faire parler les
indices en des indices sur des objets à
travers des empreintes digitales
retrouvées grâce à des poudres ou des
pinceaux mais aussi des prélèvements
biologiques pour retrouver de l'adn
je vais donc imbibé est couillon à
l'aide d'une petite goutte d'eau stérile
là je passe sur toute la zone où
potentiellement la personne a posé ses
lèvres qui les lèvres dit ça livre qui
lie salive diadème autre type
d'intervention les cambriolages ou les
vols ici une plaque d'immatriculation
d'un véhicule dérobé vient d'arriver au
laboratoire il va être analysé donc elle
est de cette machine l'acculent de
fumigation on va passer notre objet dans
la cuve
elle abat produits spécifiques comment
passer sous la coupelle nous allons le
placer à l'intérieur et lancé son cycle
ainsi que qui dure à peu près une
quarantaine de minutes et qui va nous
permettre de révéler ou non s'il ya des
empreintes digitales sur le support une
fois la réaction chimique effectué
l'objet est amenée en selle d'optique
une fois qu on a appliqué notre laurent
on passe notre objet souvent photos à
l'aide de l'appareil que vous voyez ici
qui va donner une intensité lumineuse et
appareils on a un filtre son appareil
photo ça va permettre et d'exciter le
support et donner une luminescence de
l'empreinte digitale quand on éteint la
lumière de la pièce on voit apparaître
clairement la révélation d'empreintes
digitales en 2017 56 dossiers ont été
traités dans le laboratoire de la
cellule d'identification criminelle 170
gendarmes de brigade sont formés dans
les yvelines pour relever des empreintes
ou de l'adn sur des situations de petite
délinquance
le sport et du football rail entouré à
d'anciennes gloires du paris saint
germain le 15e trophée gol de letra se
dérouler samedi au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines un rendez-vous
à caritatif pour les enfants brésiliens
défavorisés ambiance festive assurée
notamment par les ultras du psg
retour sur l'événement avec michael et
demi d'euros et nicolas landry rail
était de retour dans les yvelines
l'ancien footballeur emblématique du psg
qui habite à croissy sur seine a été
reçu à l'hôtel du département à
versailles dans le cadre du trophée gol
de letra un tournoi caritatif organisé
cette année au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pour récolter
des dons en faveur des enfants
défavorisés au brésil pour le soutenir
le département lui a remis un chèque de
dix mille euros c'est essentiel pour qui
on puisse continuer voilà la trame havas
20 en plus des vingt mille enfants et
jeunes sont déjà passées on peut on
espère continuer dans le monde
dès qu'il fera quelque chose on sera pas
loin de pouvoir l'aider parce qu'on on a
toujours cru en cette heure bien qu'on
le croit encore aujourd'hui d'alors
qu'il ait troqué ses tenues de
footballeur pour celles d'ambassadeur au
grand coeur le lendemain parfum de
brésil envahi le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines avec au
programme des spectacles de batucada et
de capoeira proposées par les clubs
locaux
ce sont ensuite les tambours du
collectif ultra du paris saint germain
qui ont investi les tribunes pour
soutenir haye les supporteurs n'ont pas
hésité à remettre un chèque de 2000
euros à la fondation
ça fait plusieurs années qu'on va voir
l'association de deux rails et voilà on
est présent à chaque année voilà c'est
important pour nous sur le terrain de
foot c'est les aficionados du psg ont pu
revoir des joueurs qui ont marqué les
travées du parc des princes comme
laurent fournier eric rabesandratana ou
bernard mendy
tout simplement parce que c'est une
bonne initiative j'ai été content car
ils m'appellent un ancien de la maison
et c'est pour une bonne cause
au travers d'un match on arrive à
récolter des fonds à rassembler aussi
beaucoup de beaucoup de personnes
et c'est vrai que ce sont bien sûr bien
c'est pas grand chose c'est qu'une
journée on donne de nous sur un terrain
on se retrouve également entre anciens
footballeurs ancien parisien dizaines
d'anciennes gloires qui ont eu du mal à
terminer la rencontre physiquement mais
l'essentiel était ailleurs pour cette
quinzième édition très productive
c'était tous les bus étaient atteints se
mobiliser les choses des sociétés et les
partenaires les collaborateurs aussi à
l'intégration
vu le succès rencontré cette année le
trophée gol de letra hérail pourrait
revenir l'année prochaine au vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines allées du
footballeur encore pour refermer ce
journal l'étau se resserre les
demi-finales de coupe des yvelines se
déroule ce dimanche 1er avril avril à
trois clubs du territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines a sont en lice
plaisir reçoit maurepas c'est au stade
bernard giroux donc dimanche 1er avril à
15h et guyancourt accueil
hardricourt les deux rencontres donc
sont à 15h alors pour en parler avec moi
en plateau guy gallant t-bonds soir
lancement vous êtes le président de
l'ess et guyancourt à ma droite ils
seront adversaires ce dimanche salim
haïk la ligne bonsoir mon sens vous êtes
le latéral droit de l'as maurepas
football et eliès adhara bonsoir bonsoir
et vous êtes le milieu défensif du fo
plaisir wa alors petit tour de table
pour commencer on va commencer avec vous
liesse dans quel état d'esprit êtes vous
à quelques jours de cette demi finale
je pense que toute l'équipe à 100% ils
pensent tous au match de dimanche est
l'état d'esprit les on sait qu'on est le
petit poucet de cette coupe et on sait
qu'on va pas démérité ce dimanche le
rappel vous évolue en division de
district les allemands vous êtes leader
d'ailleurs on aura peut-être l'occasion
d'en reparler
salim vous quel état d'esprit à quelques
jours voilà on est bien
psychologiquement on a retrouvé une
envie de gagner une belle victoire suivi
la victoire ce week-end où on gagne
contre 9,1 on a retrouvé des
automatismes une envie de marquer et
donc ça fait plaisir quoi donc je pense
aussi on pense au match de dimanche et
sa masse qu'on attend avec impatience et
du côté de lyon courtier reçoit
redécouvrons l'appel ce week-end quel
état d'esprit
ben le même je pense que tout le monde
est motivé un match de coupe c'est très
spécial c'est c contrairement au
championnat c'est je gagne je passe j'ai
bien du jeu fait limité donc les
histoires elle vous fait rêver cette
coupe on a tendance à dire que c'est un
bonus par rapport au championnat est ce
qu'elle est plus importante que le
championnat au stade actuel comment
quand on arrive en demi-finale c'est
différent parce que le championnat bon
ça joue toute la saison
lassé c'est vraiment que la cerise sur
le gâteau c'est c'est un phénomène
différent d'ailleurs parce qu'on aborde
complètement différemment un match de
coupe c'est pas un match de championnat
où on peut se récupérer là c'est voilà
c'est couperet quoi je passe je suis
fort juillet et puis on a beaucoup de
surprises parce que on découvre et on
les résultats le montrent des équipes
dites inférieures peuvent battre des
niveaux 1 2 3 supérieur
et on voit souvent justement du côté de
plaisir et de maurepas vous êtes tous
les deux dans des positions sur le
devant et du tableau en championnat 2e
pour le championnat d1 pour maurepas
premier pour le championnat de d2 pur
plaisir et que du coup cette coupe elle
est aussi importante que le championnat
yes pour nous oui on la maison mais
piédestal même si le championnat je
pense que c'est l'objectif principal
d'accord on va pas se mentir que dans la
tête de tout le monde c'est la coupe ce
serait pas mal d'aller la chercher
salim ben c'est pareil c'est bon la
coupe c'est ça reste quand même un bonus
pour nous les joueurs voilà si on a
envie pour le club aussi on en est allé
gagner comme disait le président de
guyancourt
ces voix là on gagne on continue on perd
on va c'est fini quoi donc c'est un
bonus et on a envie de gagner et on rase
aussi concentrer sur le championnat que
aussi un objectif très important pour le
club
et justement comment vous abordez vous
ce match vous affrontez donc plaisir qui
est leader d'une des poules de d2 c'est
un match qui ne sera pas à prendre à la
légère malgré la division d'écart
oui et non c'est pas un match contre ans
qu'on va prendre à la légère on a
regardé on connaît plaisir ils sont
premiers de leur championnat avec 12
victoires 1 nul 3 défaites
ils ont gagné aussi ce week-end de 5,0 à
porcheville donc voilà on sait tout peut
jouer sur un match et voilà la
motivation aussi la casse waldock il ya
son appât porno repas malgré sept
divisions d'écart une peur de personne
et du côté de lui en cours alors adri
course et
le constat c'est que vous les avez déjà
affrontées en championnat il ya eu deux
partout au match aller donc vous les
connaissez bien finalement oui on espère
bien bon il n'ya pas d'à priori
appareils la coupe c'est quelque chose
qui appartient plus aux joueurs
d'ailleurs je dirai pas ce que ce qui
est plus important c'est le championnat
mais c'est vrai que l'adrénaline qui a
autour d'un match de coupe ça gomme
toutes les déficiences physiques
techniques da club par rapport à un
autre
on peut s'en passer voilà je dirais que
le critère le plus important dans les
matchs de coupe c'est le mental
thual a très bien paru effectivement si
le groupe est uni pour aller chercher
une victoire
le mental fera gommer toutes les
différences nous reste une minute sur la
semaine d'entraînement est ce que c'est
une semaine comme les autres où ça va se
préparer quand même assez
particulièrement ce match dit pour nous
pour nous c'est un l'identique peut-être
une séance de penalty ce qui sera
travaillé aux entraînements mais je suis
pas le coach d'homme c'est pas moi qui
vais en parler
une séance de pénalties je crois que
c'est lors du dernier tour c'était le
scénario du match je mords pas ouais bah
on jouait contre les mureaux qui sont
premiers du championnat aussi donc voilà
on a réussi à égaliser en fin de match
donc après aux tirs au but voilà c'est
c'est quitte ou double 1 donc c est bien
sûr la préparation ou est-ce que ça va
être particulier cette semaine vont ça
va être comme les autres semaines
non je pense que ça va jouer dans la
tête de tous les joueurs moi le premier
on sait qu'on a une grosse échéance le
dimanche d'après donc ça va se donner à
2007 sonné eh ben on vous souhaite bonne
chance même si vous êtes adversaire
bonne chance à vous donc je rappelle les
rencontres dimanche 1er avril 15h
plaisir reçoit maurepas au stade bernard
giroux et guyancourt de son côté
accueillera hardricourt les deux
rencontres je précise elles sont à 15
heures merci à vous je rappelle le nom
des invités guy galanti président de
l'ess et guyancourt
alliès adhara milieu défensif aux
plaisirs oies et salima icloud in icaic
abeline pardon
je vais y arriver donc les latéral droit
ales maurepas merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de l'avoir suivi replay et
reportages à retrouver sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
soixante dix huit belles soirées
excellente semaine à tous
[Musique]